est ce que tu trouves que la télé
aujourd'hui et vous on roule mendes que
la clé du pur et dur est devenu trop
coincé jour montrer une image c'était
vincent lagaf vincent star de tf1
l'époque lui regardez il est dans le
midi et regardez l'extrait franchement à
l'époque ça passait et regardait ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça passerait sa jeunesse
avant 2013 a nettement ceux qui ont
trouvé levier lever la main alors qu'il
avait demandé foyer quelque chose à
gagner tu vas les iguanes et moi j'avais
trouvé danesi il me le garde lui lève
pas la veille fait coucou à la famille à
barbezieux
c'est vrai que vous avez des cadeaux
mais il ya des cousins rouge ça
passerait pas à 100 mais ça passait pas
non c'est cesser ces points je sais pas
quoi dire moi je suis tu sais ce qui est
terrible en plus surtout c'est que tous
ces gens qui qui vont gueuler contre les
machins et tous et qui empêche les gens
de s'exprimer c'est les mêmes qui
défilaient dans les rues avec le tee
shirt je suis charlie protéger la
liberté d'expression sans savoir s'il ya
une liberté d'expression si on a deux
s'il ya des choses est ce que c'est
vraiment raciste de prendre l'accent
africain je suis franchement mail en
question pensent surtout faut se
remettre dans le contexte elle a bien
sûr fait oui il n'y a personne qui est
choqué sur le plat que le plateau sap a
fait polémique à l'époque aujourd'hui
j'aurais peut-être une polémique mais
faut se remettre en contact voire non
mais le rater là aujourd'hui on doit à
ses trop coincé ça ne peut plus avoir
des animateurs comme la gaffe qui était
qu'est comme tu as dit c'est un
animateur voilà il anime inutiles ou
géraldine c'est la télé coincé parce que
le monde est devenu coincé et on fait de
la télé ni par le prisme des réseaux
sociaux des procès en temps réel
n'importe quelle sorte âge surtout ce
qui lui fait peur des procureurs avec
les télécommandes et en fait c'est ça
chez nous c'est que c'est
contreproductif
mais où le racisme c'est une chose il
faut vraiment se battre contre les
choses qu'ils sont graves pour les actes
de racisme grave et ça j'ai l'impression
que ça des voix un peu la cause mais
séoul 1%
mais là on n'avait rien gagné on va
sortir des archives de linate dans le
but de les juger
aujourd'hui ce qui est gravissime j'ai
quand même dû demander
aujourd'hui c'est juste pour montrer aux
gens de vivre ailleurs il y aura aussi
il ya quelques années dans la nouvelle
star regardez regardez cette séquence
dites-moi si elle pourrait passer
aujourd'hui
pardon on recommence toujours bonjour
bonjour bonjour je m'appelle tu quand
kim joo continu du contenu même du
compte on va t'appeler luc vous venez
d'où je viens de la corée du sud du coup
vous allez nous chanter de la pop star
voilà alors la séquence avait fait
polémique à l'époque je comprends pas
non là mais on a alors c'est pas grave
du tout c'est l'humour de joeystarr
c'est plutôt rigolo alors franchement ça
pourrait passer aujourd'hui déjà la
musique de fond médiatique quand le
quand le mékong saurait ni insultes
auraient fait polémique et on voit bien
que ça a changé la monnaie dans un monde
d'offusquer nuit donc tout le monde
s'indigne pour tout et n'importe quoi
n'importe quelle petite communauté
forcément on va aller de sa de sa
victimisation très compliquée pour tout
et n'importe quoi parce que moi j'ai été
viré parce que j'étais un homme blanc de
plus de 50 ans
mais vous vous êtes assis mais
aujourd'hui et en plus hétéro alors là
c'est la ses 50 ans et vulgaire parce
que maintenant le diplôme mais je suis
désolée la direction le disait mon il
est vulgaire sentir le plus grand
cabaret du monde tu vas pas y trouver
beaucoup de bien ça c'est fini ça mais
c'est pas moi qui lis ça c'est un qui
disait ça ouais
après c'est ce ce qu'ils disent et ce
après c'est pas plus guère populaire
voilà j'ai entendu dix fois vulgaire et
franchement il m'est arrivé de dire
effectivement des gros mots parce que je
parle avec le langage de la rue mais
dans le cabaret si vous trouvez beaucoup
de choses julien je pense pas non c'est
ton tranquille on trouve beaucoup par
rapport à ce que son taux est ce que je
vois dans les bars rayés dans l'est
partout où je vais je vois des choses où
je me dis mais bon c'est en même temps
c'est l'époque voilà cette époque là les
joies du 3 et d'avoir mon âge parce que
j'ai vécu j'ai eu la chance sur un
privilégié
ça fait rêver lire tous les nombres de
25 ans qui moyen des [ __ ] qu'est ce
que tu as eu la chance de vivre dans les
années 80 et je les plains - lé monde
d'aujourd'hui plus on monte les gens
montrer une autre image c'est de
reprendre les sister tueur à l'époque et
il est très tactile à être une des
candidates de l'émission s'est passé à
l'époque
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ça passerait
regarde
allez détendez vous détendez vous le van
kim avait rappelé pour savoir si c'était
quand même d'accord pour boire un verre
j'ai dit non ça va pas ou alors oui bon
ça va bien c'est bien si c'est bien
ferme c'est vous avez un objet fétiche
la chaîne il ya quoi savourer cheney un
petit coeur qu'est-ce qui vous l'a
offert c'est ma mort tous c'est votre
moment d'accord très jolie chaîne vidéo
excusez moi je sais pas ce que j'ai
c'est l'amour vraiment une autre boîte
britney elle tremble de partout et j'ose
pas vous attrapez les jambes
est ce que c'est moi qui vous aident non
non non je défends pas arthur en plus
vous le savez moi arthur à l'époque il
faisait ça avec tous les candidats même
des candidats
rappelle moi je regardais alors moi je
pouvais pas le faire quand j'animais
apprendre au lycée parce qu'il y avait
un gros bide mais c'est vrai que il
faisait ça même avec des candidats il
aima c'est que ce soit des hommes se
soient des femmes
je me rappelle c'est un petit peu le jeu
parce que en italie en fait c'est un jeu
qui cartonnait aussi en italie et le mec
les litanies aussi il était très tactile
et je crois que voilà ils se sont tous
inspirés lui mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ça là aujourd'hui ce sera
impossible isabelle année là s'est il
alors d'abord sur la twittosphère et se
fait massacrer les races et je pense
qu'il pourrait y avoir un retrait de
l'émission quelque chose comme ça ça va
aussi loin que ça bernard montiel
moi je te soutiens des cronulla la
seconde guerre mondiale j'ai collé tout
ça non mais je regrette on a tellement
rigolé avec patrick en plus on en a fait
des coûts nous écoute a été interdite
des difficultés étaient très chauds
c'est quoi qu'est ce que vous avez fait
je lui avais fait faire sarkozy il eu
ensemble est vachement ça à l'époque où
sarkozy était amoureux enfin été avec
balladur frais est ils étaient dans une
chambre en peignoir il ya des photos de
balladur et au mur et il chante et je ne
suis que de l'amour
il me traite comme un chien moyen mais
ça a été très très loin je me suis fait
ça par la mission a pas été interdite
c'est vrai que je me suis fait pourrir
je suis dit c'est l'humour fait on avait
mis des génies mitterrand porte
jarretelles j'ai mis en art on a fait on
a fait détruire les intéressés c'est
marrant parce que souvent les intéressés
eux mêmes s'en foutent basse et les
autres tours qui disent ah mais ça c'est
pas bien alors on va avoir une idée
aussi coucou c'est nous on l'attend là
que l'américain edwards qui est un
humoriste voilà et c'est vrai qu'avec
sophie favier sont là et mina est ce que
ça pourrait passer aujourd'hui rien
s'est un fait un petit bisou à django
sais pas trop
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si nous regarde mais wayne faught louis
guillot ça montre bien que les
mentalités ont changé depuis quelques
années seulement parce que cette
séquence il ya quelques années il était
encore dans les bêtisiers sur tf1 et
tout le monde se marre et on trouvait
que c'était marrant aujourd'hui ça
choque tout le monde
alors il ya un autre truc que je voulais
montrer c'était dans les années 80 une
émission culte qui s'appellent eux
c'était le collaro show et il y avait
tous les samedis à rejoindre autour de
19 heures il y avait ce qu'on appelle la
playmate et y avait une jeune fille qui
était anonyme une anonyme elle était bas
voilà les elle est caissière à
l'infirmière juste pressé en famille
tout ça il était 19h45
ils ont mangé des petits pots voilà le
but c'est vrai et y avait donc il nous
présentait une jeune fille tient karine
infirmières c'est notre playmate de la
semaine et donc et venez faire un strip
tease à 20h à juste avant le journal sur
téva regarde toutes et tous et toutes
les senteurs des mers du sud dans un
flacon de mary voir
[Musique]
les demoiselles c'est incroyable non
mais franchement ça ou si ma vie et je
vous le jure marché vous ça passait à
cette heure ci genre tu es tranquille
chez toi tu avec tes parents tous à
terre est en train de manger le rosbif
et tu vois ce à quoi tu as un truc d
excellents pour l'audience est à sa
quatrième occasion jean-louis ce sera la
révolution
l'émission interdite les gens dans la
rue mais c'est vrai qu'avec une
représentation même du corps féminin
c'était différent à l'époque mais
franchement quand même il ya quelques
séquences qu'on voit là celle-là
moi je dis heureusement qu'on ne peut
plus faire ça aujourd'hui mais moi moi
ça me perturbe ray qu'on puisse faire ça
aujourd'hui mais regardez regardez la
question c'est en fait est ce que le
monde ait beaucoup étaient bien pire
avance à espira les gens étaient plus
raciste plus sexistes plus stigmatisant
plus tordus du coin c'est enfin plus
méchant moi je crois pas en fait je
pense que voilà je ne pense pas que mon
voyant ces images on était on était plus
pourris qu'aujourd'hui on pense et moi
on penser - un mal je pense nous devant
ces images là à l'époque maintenant
maintenant tu verrais des intentions bah
moi je pense qu'il est quand même on
peut faire encore ce qu'on veut à la
télévision je ne fais un petit strip
tease non si vous voulez alors je pense
qu'on peut dire ce qu'on veut d'ailleurs
il ya juste à regarder certaines télé
réalité où c'est quand même très
vulgaire par mois
franchement on peut dire ce qu'on veut
après ces 5 sur tf1 de france 2 des
chaînes hertziennes où il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de dymat on fait plus attention
on a quand même une liberté de ton dans
ce pays
au regard des deux pays comment ça se
passe on peut quand même dire ce qu'on
veut en france comiquement oui oui oui
oui
est-ce qu'on veut dire ce qu'on veut je
suis d'accord aujourd'hui je trouve que
la parole est plus libre
il y avait quand même de la censure mais
faire ce qu'on veut non voilà c'est ça
c'est les arbitres qui aujourd'hui sont
absolument impossible ah non on peut
plus ça on peut plus faire ça patrick
lauret convoiterait contractuels qui a
changé moi je me suis engagé tf1 et sur
l'a5 j'avais un contrat où j'avais la
liberté éditoriale de dire tout ce que
je voulais sauce de troubler l'ordre
public c'est à dire d'être à l'envers de
la loi chose qu'il a toujours respecté
mais depuis une dizaine d'années c'est
devenu complètement autre chose
c'est-à-dire que moi mais ces missions
il y avait des gens qui étaient dans la
sall avait deux personnes dans la salle
qui a appelé tout de suite la chaîne
milan il a dit ça il a dit ça et on me
disait coupez coupez coupez coupez la
soutiendra d'auzan où tu sortais d'une
braguette moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
plus du tout envie de revenir dans ce
milieu là parce que j'ai envie d'être
libre
j'ai pas envie qu'on me coupe ça ne fait
plus rêver la télé aujourd'hui patrick
comment ça ne fait plus rêver la télé
aujourd'hui pas comme ça un long moment
non on est assez grand pour savoir les
limites qu'on ne doit pas tu sais quand
j'étais allé interviewer mitterrand il
m'a dit la censure ne doit pas ça serait
la pierre pour écraser la mouche me
rappelle très bien ce qui m'a dit ce
qu'il faut c'est vous trouviez vous même
les limites de votre bon goût
merci à moi il semble que j'ai au mieux
j'ai essayé de protéger il ya des mecs
dans mes émissions qui m'ont ignorée de
dire s'agit non tu le dis pas parce que
c'est parce que tu vas blesser quelqu'un
vient et c'est tact a connu tu as connu
tous les présidents
ouais j'ai fait de l'auto sens je fais
des projets qui en dix ans ça tu peux
pas le dire parce que tu vas blessés
patrick était proche de jacques chirac
très proche tu connais c'est bien
françois hollande aussi parce que tu
essaies de brive les chirac mais jax
battue c'est quand chirac est mort si
une certaine france y est mort il ya
cette france-là chirac aujourd'hui il ya
en prendre plein la gueule parce que les
blagues un peu la bière à la main le
machin etc
c'est tous tu le président m'a tout ce
qui a été fait virer quand tu continues
ton quand ils t'ont arrêté france télé
oui tu as dit quoi je te jure est pas
moi qui m'a dit c'est dès qu'on a dit
c'est des cons je te le dirai pas ce te
le dirai pas le président de macron
c'est le président ma grand voile assez
je suis pas je parais navire cardete
émission je suis pas un ami intime gens
pensent pas chirac oui les regarder
chirac l'a regardé chirac les regarder
régulièrement parce qu'il aime le cirque
vraiment même toutes ces choses là
et puis je te dis on est des vieux cons
ok c'est une autre époque
ok mais [ __ ] qu'est ce que vous avez
raté alors on va revoir
qu'est ce qu'on se marre et on va voir
france d'avoir des horizons les années
bonheur ça tout à l'heure on regarde
était ni plus raciste mais regardez moi
aussi vous allez me manquer même si on
retrouve science l on se retrouve sur
scène
vous allez me manquer et puis je voulais
vous dire aussi que je suis fier
finalement je suis fier pendant toutes
ces années de m'être jamais trahi jamais
ne nous avons trahi et vous c'est à dire
d'avoir fait des émissions populaires et
d'avoir résisté tant que j'ai pu à la
bien pensants c'est le politiquement
correct et [ __ ] je suis arrivé
jusqu'au bout et j'ai tenu bon
[Applaudissements]
samedi sébastien les résultats du
sondage c'est sûr penser oui à 88% voilà
non à 12% envoyer la télé est devenue
trop coincé c'est vous qui le dites